الآن من لندن السفير حسام حموت
رئيس البعثة الفلسطينية لدى
المملكة المتحدة السفير مساء الخير
متأخرا عليك أيضا أنا ممتن
لوقتك شكرا لك سيدي أم أعني اليوم
انظر الاحتفال هو كلمة خاطئة أنا
أود أن أقول ربما الإغاثة هي
كلمة أفضل أه أن بعض من أنه
تم إطلاق سراح بعض الرهائن وفي
المقابل بالطبع المعتقلون في
طريقهم إلى المنزل أيضًا ما هي الكلمة التي ستستخدمها
سأستخدم بصيص من الأمل أه أن
هذه المذبحة ستنتهي أه أه  سوف
ننتقل فورًا إلى
بحر دائم وشامل بعيدًا، إنه حقًا أمر
غير معقول إلى حد ما أه أن ندفع لأيام
نطعم أطفالنا ومدنيينا
ثم يستأنفون القتل الجماعي لهم
كما كنتم تنشرون التقارير طوال
الشهر ونصف الشهر الماضي لذلك كل
يجب أن تغتنم جهودنا بصيص الأمل هذا
لتحويله إلى أمل أكبر بكثير لوقف
الفظائع وإيقافها الآن، أعني في
نفس الوقت السفير الذي نتحدث
عنه، أعني عندما أعتقد أننا عرضة لإغفال
الحقيقة عندما نتحدث
عن إطلاق سراح الرهائن وما إلى ذلك،
لكن هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يبلغون من العمر 85 عامًا
وأطفال يبلغون من العمر 9 سنوات يتم دفعهم على دراجة نارية، وقد تم
اختطاف هؤلاء الأشخاص من قبل حماس، وأنا
أفهم أنك لن تفعل ذلك، أعني أنك
لن تفعل ذلك.  لا أوافق على ذلك
بأي شكل من الأشكال ولكننا فقط
نتحدث هنا حقًا عن الأشخاص الذين
تم اختطافهم وتم إطلاق سراحهم من قبل
خاطفيهم حسنًا ريتشارد اه، أنت تعرف أم،
يجب أن أتحداك هنا وأقول ذلك
بينما أهنئك على ما ذكرته أه  أه
أه هؤلاء الرهائن وجيد أنه تم
إطلاق سراحهم يجب أه إطلاق سراحهم أه
أقصد الرهائن الإسرائيليين
ولكن أه لماذا لم تسألني عن
الرهائن الفلسطينيين الأطفال الذين
تم إطلاق سراحهم اليوم والذين كانوا
في السجون الإسرائيلية قبل السابع
في تشرين الأول/أكتوبر، كما تعلمون، لدينا مئات
الأطفال الفلسطينيين الذين أوقفتهم
إسرائيل على مدى سنوات وسنوات دون
تهمة ودون محاكمة ودون الوصول إلى
محام أو إلى أسرهم وأولياء أمورهم،
وهذا أمر غير معقول حقًا،
ولا ينتمي حتى إلى يومنا هذا
وإنسانيتنا و  هذا هو الوقت المناسب
للتركيز حقًا على النظام الشامل
لقمع القمع وأنت
تعرف ما يعنيه الأمر، إنه
يخبرنا كثيرًا أن الكثير من
وسائل الإعلام الدولية تركز حقًا على السفير السفير لمدة
دقيقة واحدة فقط، والسبب
بسيط أولاً وقبل كل شيء.  كنت قادمًا إلى
الفلسطينيين، نعم أخبرني بالسبب،
أخبرني ريتش بالسبب المؤكد لأنه
عندما ننظر إلى الصور التي توضح كيفية
اختطاف هؤلاء الأشخاص، تم إلقاء جميع النساء المسنات فوق
دراجات نارية وهم يصرخون وتم الاستيلاء عليها عبر
الحدود، وتم دفعهم إلى أسفل الأنفاق التي ظلت مظلمة
هناك  هناك
فرق كمي ونوعي
في طريقة الاحتجاز بين سأخبرك
سأخبرك ما هو
الفرق سأخبرك حقًا ما هو
الفرق الفرق هو
الأول يتم بواسطة الأفراد ولكن
الثاني  تقوم به دولة من قبل دولة
برعاية جيش
تغزو ذراعه منازل الأبرياء في
منتصف الليل في
الساعات الأولى من الصباح أيقظ هؤلاء
الأطفال في أشد
حالات رعب
ARG لذا فإن الحجة التي تتقدم بها هي  لقد سألتني لقد سألتني
سأجيبك،
إنه من المخزي أن يتم حتى إقامة أي
عدالة بين دولة عضو
في الأمم المتحدة وهي إسرائيل
ومسؤوليتها بموجب القانون الدولي
وبين الأفراد، لذلك في
الواقع عدم المساواة  هو التركيز
على المسؤولين بين
الجهات الفاعلة بين قوسين والتي يجب أن يؤديوها بما
يتفق تمامًا مع إجابة
السفير، لقد أجبت، دعنا نستمر في
تحريك واقع الوضع
الليلة حيث دعت الولايات المتحدة أم رئيس الولايات المتحدة إلى
اه اثنين
حل الدولة، ولكن في الوقت نفسه
قال رئيس وزراء إسرائيل حسنًا،
مهما حدث في غزة، فإن
السلطة الفلسطينية لن تكون
قادرة على استعادة السيطرة أو لن تكون
سلطتها هي المسيطرة، مما
يوحي بأن السلطة الفلسطينية
سوف  لن يكون لي دور في كل ما يحدث
في غزة
بعد الحرب، حسنًا،
هذه هي بالضبط أجندة نتنياهو وهذه هي أجندته
منذ أن تولى منصبه في
إسرائيل على مدى ربع قرن الأخير
وهو يتحدث علنًا عن ذلك ريتشارد
القضية هنا التي لا نفعلها  "لا نستمع إلى
السياسيين والقادة الإسرائيليين،
ولا نعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن نبدأ في الاستماع
إليهم، لقد كان ناناهو يقول إنه موجود
هناك لعرقلة عملية أوسو بأكملها، وقد
فعل ذلك، وهو موجود هناك لمنع
تنفيذ حل الدولتين".  جزء من ذلك هو عدم السماح
بوجود جبهة جغرافية سياسية فلسطينية موحدة،
جزء من ذلك هو
الحفاظ على الانقسام، جزء من ذلك
يقوض منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية ومهاجمة
منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية، جزء من ذلك هو ما يفعلونه
ونحن نتحدث في الضفة الغربية عن المستوطنين غير الشرعيين  إن
شن غارات جوية في جميع أنحاء
الضفة الغربية أسفر عن مقتل أكثر من 200 شخص في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية منذ بدء الحرب على
غزة، وجزء من ذلك هو
المنطق القائل بأن نتنياهو يمكنه إبقاء
الاحتلال دائمًا وتجاوز
الشعب الفلسطيني، لذا فهذه لحظة
الحقيقة.  بالنسبة له ولأي شخص
تابعه طوال هذه السنوات،
قال الرئيس أيضًا وقال
إنه لا يستطيع إثبات ذلك لكنه كان
متأكدًا تمامًا من أن هناك شيئًا ما فيه
أه وأنا متأكد من أنك سمعت
الرئيس بايدن  لكنه قال إن
السبب وراء ارتكاب حماس لعملها الوحشي في
7 أكتوبر هو أن المحادثات مع المملكة العربية
السعودية حول التطبيع أو على الأقل
التقرب من إسرائيل أو
اتفاقيات إبراهيم أو غير ذلك أصبحت
أكثر واقعية، هل تعتقد يا سيدي أن هذا
ليس كذلك؟  هناك دائمًا سبب وجيه
لما فعلوه ولكنه
يفسر بدلاً من الأعذار لماذا، ثم ما
فعلوه بسبب اقتراب السعودية،
تعلمون هذا أه هذا النوع
من اللقطة لهذا الوضع، دعني
أخبرك بهذا أه أه أه
الصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي أه  الصراع لم يكن
سببه أه حماس أو أي مجموعة أخرى
إنه صراع 100 عام هو
الصراع الذي يسبب ويخلق كل
هذه المجموعات السياسية الفلسطينية أه أه والجماعات
المسلحة أه طوال
تاريخنا وربما يحتاج العالم إلى
الولايات المتحدة بشكل خاص أه أه اذهب  مباشرة إلى
السبب الجذري لكل هذا
وهو الاحتلال العسكري غير القانوني،
هذه ليست مشكلة، هذه ليست
مشكلة بين العرب والعرب أو بين الفلسطينيين
والفلسطينيين، هذه مشكلة مع
56 56 عامًا من الاحتلال الإسرائيلي و
75 عامًا من الاحتلال العرقي  التطهير ولهذا
السبب لديك الوضع الذي لدينا اليوم
ونحن نناقش اليوم نحن بحاجة
للذهاب إلى الخط المستقيم إلى
الروتا وهذا عادل بما فيه الكفاية يا سيدي
أسمع ما تقوله ولكن الآن يرجى
الإجابة على سؤالي، هل تعتقد ذلك؟  أن
هناك أي شيء في الحقيقة أن
المحفز لهذا الفعل بين الحين والآخر
هو حقيقة أن السعودية كانت
تقترب من تطبيع العلاقات مع
إسرائيل وإذا كان الأمر كذلك فإن
أمل حماس في القيام بما فعلته
والذي نجح أبعد من ذلك  أي
أحلام محتملة، هل تعتقد أن هناك أي
حقيقة في
أن الشيء الوحيد الذي كان من شأنه أن
يخرج أي نوع من
التطبيع في المنطقة عن مساره هو
السياسات والأفعال الإسرائيلية وكانت المملكة العربية السعودية
على الإطلاق قد كانت
واضحة تمامًا في رغبتها في رؤيتها
كحل للإسرائيليين، أنا
آسف للصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني،
إنهم يريدون رؤية نهاية
الاحتلال ويريدون رؤية
حل الدولتين، وبالتالي ما
كان يمكن أن يتوقف هو ما قاله
الشعب السعودي والسعودي  لقد كان القادة
يشاهدون على أجهزة التلفزيون الخاصة بهم
الفظائع الإسرائيلية وجرائم الحرب
والتطهير العرقي لشعبنا في غزة وفي
الضفة الغربية لذلك أه ما يجمعنا
جميعًا كمنطقة وأمس أول أمس
انضممت أه كثيرين
وزراء خارجية أه السعودية
من الدول العربية والدول الإسلامية
يجتمعون مع وزير خارجية
بريطانيا هنا السيد ديفيد كاميرون وهناك
موقف موحد بأن هذه
المرة هو وقت التركيز على
السبب الجذري هذه المرة هو تأييد الاحتلال
وليس  المضي قدمًا في العملية
والاتفاقيات المؤقتة المطولة، هذا هو
الوقت الذي نقوم فيه بعمل كبير لإنهاء
هذا العمل مرة واحدة وإلى الأبد
السفير أه مناقشة قوية لكن
وجهة نظرك وصلت هناك، شكرًا لك
على تخصيص الوقت أه للتحدث معنا هذا
المساء.  أنا ممتن شكرا
ريتشارد